If there's one thing I can guarantee you,
it's this.
If you are way too sensitive, way too sensitive,
and you were raised in this family where your
mama told you you're so perfect and no one's
going to ever do anything wrong to you, and
you decide to go into the world of business,
bam!
You're going to say that hurt.
And you're not going to stay as an entrepreneur.
Because in the world of business, it can get
very, very ugly at times.
And I'm simply trying to emotionally, mentally
prepare you for the beat down that you're
going to get if you become an entrepreneur.
So, today, I'm going to talk to you about
eight bad experiences that will help you as
an entrepreneur.
So let's start off with point #1.
Here's point #1.
A very, very embarrassing and humiliating
experience that you had.
What could that be?
I don't know what it is.
But it's got to be very embarrassing.
It's got to be very humiliating.
It could be you going in school and you're
trying to play football and you go to tryout
and you play basketball and you're so embarrassing
that everybody laughs at you.
That moment of laughter, you will forever
remember, if you have that moment of laughter.
If you have a moment where you wanted to go
out there and try to play a certain game or
try to go talk to a certain girl or try to
do something, and you were so embarrassed,
so humiliated, that that stays with your spirit.
That's actually a good thing.
Because in business, it's going to happen
many times.
So if it hasn't happened yet once and it happens
in business, you're going to say, oh, that
hurts.
I'm not going to do that again.
And you'll leave.
Second one, being bullied.
It's very important to be bullied.
Here's why it's very important to be bullied.
And I know a lot of times I did a video once
called how to handle bullies.
I think the video's called how to handle bullies.
And I cannot stand bullies.
If there's two affirmations I give to my kids.
Every night I come home and ask them two questions.
Daddy, do we bully people?
No.
Do we get bullied?
Both are answered no.
One we don't bully anybody.
Two, we don't bully people.
I expect four things from my kids.
Lead people, improve daily, love, and improve.
That's it.
Those are four things.
Simple.
But we don't bully people.
But it's the best thing that happens to you.
Why?
My younger son gets bullied by the older son.
The younger son gets pushed, gets hit, gets
all this other stuff.
When he becomes 14 years old, and he gets
into a fight with a kid, you know how my younger
son's going to handle it?
He's going be like, dude, I've been fighting
my older brother for years.
You're nobody to me.
Let's go fight.
What do you want to do?
Do you want to fight?
Let's fight.
Mario's got a younger brother, right?
Your younger brother.
Mario's told me stories, David, right?
Mario's told me stories about his younger
brother.
What stories have you told me about him fighting?
(Mario: he fought a guy double his size).
And whopped his tail.
(Mario: knocked him out.)
How old was he at the time?
(Mario: 14 years old.)
Why?
Because David has two older brothers or three
older brothers?
(Mario: five.)
He's got five older brothers.
Do you think that kid is going to grow up
being bullied a little bit?
It helps in business.
So if you've been bullied before, if someone's
- I remember being a kid in Iran, I remember
being a kid in Germany, I remember being a
kid in.
. . I was bullied over and over and over again.
It made me tougher.
Many of these MMA fighters, when you study
them, you study many of these MMA fighters,
there's one thing they all have in common.
You know what it is?
They all say, Why did you become a fighter?
Because I got bullied.
Why did you become a fighter?
Because I got bullied, man.
Eventually I was so sick and tired of being
bullied, I wanted to whoop his ass.
So I became tough.
And that's why I do MMA.
And that guy doesn't fight me anymore.
This is not a new thing.
This is a very, I know this stuff is strange,
so parents are not going to share this video
with their kids.
No, honey, don't watch this video because
this man, this Iranian, Assyrian, Armenian,
scary-looking big man says you need to be
bullied.
Baby, don't watch this video!
Unsubscribe from Valuetainment, right?
But in reality, it's a good thing that happens
to you.
Next, rejected.
Being rejected is a very good thing.
You know why?
I have a hard time.
I've been mentoring sales people for 15 years.
You know what their fear is?
They see this [phone], they scream like a
little girl, when they see a phone.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Hey, John, this thing, you got to pick up,
and you got to make phone calls.
No, no.
Yes.
No, I won't do it!
Yes!
No!
Why not?
Because they can't handle one word that's
got only two letters in it.
At least be scared of a 16 letter word.
Why are you going to be scared of a two-letter
word?
No.
Be scared of a technical word.
All they're telling you is no.
Not interested.
No.
You know this hurts, just the last three seconds,
you listening to me saying no, it hurts you.
Some of you even stopped watching the video,
because you hate the word no.
No is good in business.
No is very good in business.
Because you get rejected.
Then you get used to it.
Then eventually what happens to you?
You're desensitized.
You know what's desensitized?
When you don't even see it any more.
You know the guy that goes to the girl and
says, hey, you look pretty, girl.
I want to take you out.
No.
Okay.
Friday or Saturday night?
I said, "no."
I'll pick you up.
What's your address?
I just told you no!
Cell number the same number?
I told you no!
Just make sure you wear a nice dress.
All right, all right.
I'll pick you up.
Boom.
I don't hear the no.
Same thing with business.
You got to be deaf to the no.
The more rejected you get, the better off
you are.
Sometimes I get these Snapchat messages, people
say, "but you don't understand how hard of
a life I've lived.
But Pat, you're so.
. . you do not sympathize with people.
You do not understand people!"
Patrick said the other day, that for him hitting
rock bottom was driving a Ford Focus.
How arrogant are you to say rock bottom is
Ford Focus?
I grew up in Iran.
I was homeless for quite some time before
joining the military.
I had nothing to eat, many, many times in
my lifetime.
Many, many times in my lifetime where I had
to live in my friends' houses and beg them.
I used to go and sell my lunch to just have
enough money to go, because I never got an
allowance for six years.
I never got an allowance.
This is this kid, never.
I had to find my own allowance.
I didn't have allowance.
So don't tell me about your life being hard.
My parents got a divorce.
My mother went back to Iran.
I don't have a clue where to live.
I don't want to hear your sympathy story.
I'm not trying to win subscribers here.
If you don't like this channel, go to a different
place that motivates you and tells you how
awesome you are.
But stop complaining to me about how difficult
your life is.
We did a video yesterday on a webinar.
It was a private webinar they won as a contest.
I'm on a call with this cat.
He says, "Well, let me tell you this."
I said, man, do you make any decisions?
Are you watching anything here?
One of the best things that can happen to
you is being rejected.
Best things.
So you, for some of you that are watching
this, that you think you had a bad life, man,
be thankful for it, because that's going to
help you in the world of business.
Not the other way around.
The guy that's been guarded and protected
by mommy and daddy so nothing bad ever happens
to them, they don't know how to handle reality
when it happens to them.
You do.
Use that as the best thing on your resume.
Not as a crutch.
As a strength.
Because it can help you in the world of business.
Next, a great breakup.
Man, one of the best things that can happen
to you is a great breakup.
I don't love you anymore.
What are you talking about?
I just don't.
I don't know what happened.
I used to love you.
I just don't love you anymore.
I don't.
Do you - is there somebody else?
Yes!
Who?
Your best friend.
No!
Which one?
Jack.
Oh my!
That's great.
Oh, that's great.
Again, Patrick, have you completely lost it?
No.
I just know when I talk to people who have
built a very big business, and you sit down
and break bread, and you really find out their
story, it is hell and back, before they build
it big.
And some of you guys are fully qualified,
just so you know that.
You just need to see the strength of it.
So break up, phenomenal thing.
Let a girl break up with you.
Oh, it's so great.
Let her say, "I don't love you anymore."
Just remember that date.
Man, that's a magical word, right?
So I'll go right into the next one -- see
if I can remember all the points.
Next one, piercing words.
Ooof.
You know what's a great thing about piercing
words?
It just goes voom.
It goes through you, and it strings, man.
It hurts.
Piercing.
You know what type of words?
I remember one time I was on a conference
call with a guy, Jose.
A very good friend of mine.
This guy wanted a conference call.
And a guy on the other line tells him this
on the conference call.
He says this to him, because at that time,
Jose wasn't doing too well in business.
They're doing very good right now.
But at that time he wasn't doing too well
in business.
He was working as a bill collector.
He'd lost everything.
The house he bought for his mom, losing and
he had to go tell his mom, mom, you got to
move out because I lost this house, mom.
Mom, I lost this house.
Tears coming in this cat's eyes.
Tears.
I remember, I remember this guy.
Okay, but he's a very, very solid guy, character
solid guy, right?
you know what happens one time we're on a
conference call.
One guy says this to him.
He says, "Let me tell you something, Jose.
You will never, you will never make it in
business.
You will never make it in business.
Do you know how many years ago that was?
'08?
'08.
Nine years ago.
It was such a piercing word, he remembers
it till today.
He remembers it till today.
I remember certain words till today.
There's a part to forgive, 100%.
But it's kind of tough to forget.
There's a part to forgive, but there's a part
you don't forget.
You remember those words.
This thing [mouth] has a lot of power.
Lots of power.
Sometimes a coach, or somebody that's even
coaching you may say certain words to you,
that are piercing.
Maybe he or she is testing you, to see how
you're going to respond.
Strong coaches are very good at doing that.
Bill Belichick, you think he's not going to
say certain things?
The other day they were talking about why,
what's the coach of the Cleveland Cavaliers?
What's the guy's name?
Tyronn Lue.
Tyronn Lue's the coach of the Cleveland Cavaliers,
used to play for the Lakers.
And there was a scene, last year in the season.
You know what the scene was?
So, Coach Blatt, was a coach that came from
Europe.
And he's a guy that everybody knew.
And they hired him to coach LeBron.
And in the middle of the season, Blatt and
LeBron are not getting along.
Blatt gets fired.
They bring Tyronn Lue.
Just so you know, Tyronn Lue's shorter than
me.
And LeBron is 6' 8" 260.
And Tyronn was about 6' 1", 6' 2, give or
take.
Maybe 6' 3".
And there is a scene.
Here's a scene.
LeBron's coming in, LeBron's coming in, Tyronn's
going out.
In the time out, LeBron starts telling Tyronn
Lue what to do.
Tyronn said, Shut the F up."
Now, I'm not telling you this is something
for you to do with your people.
This is sports.
In sports there's locker rooms.
It's heated.
It's different than business.
Completely different than business.
But there was a heated moment.
He said to LeBron, I'm the coach.
Be quiet.
I'm the coach.
I'm not Blatt.
LeBron sits.
Listens.
Tyronn draws out the play.
They go, they win the game.
They ask LeBron afterwards what'd you think
about that?
He said, "I respected him for it.
Because that's the reason why he's our coach."
And then they won the championship together.
And the prior coach couldn't do that.
Couldn't do that.
Sometimes piercing words, boom!
Hey, let's go.
Let's do something with it.
You've got to remember some of those piercing
words.
Then, when you do get piercing words, it's
all about how you respond to piercing words.
Because there's two different ways people
respond to piercing words.
One of them is what?
I can't believe he said that to me.
I'm just such a loser.
And I'm this and I'm pouting and I'm going
to my mommy and I'm crying to my daddy.
I can't believe this."
We're like, "you know what, let me prove him
wrong!
Let me go out there and prove myself that
I can do this."
Then go do it.
It's completely on you.
But the more opportunities you have like that,
the more opportunity you have to just scale,
your capacity just goes, I got to do something
big with this thing here.
You got to be able to do something big with
that.
The other one.
A very, very, very good ass whooping.
That's a very good thing to happen to people.
Why?
You know why?
Let me tell you why.
One of the reasons why it's very good to have
your ass handed to you is because it tells
you you're not as bad as you think you are.
Meaning, you're not as tough as you think
you are.
And you're not as great as you think you are.
There's always somebody out there that can
kick your butt.
There's nothing greater than that.
There's nothing greater than you walking around
thinking you're tough, and then somebody gets
you.
Because you realize, every single day you're
competing, don't underestimate anybody.
Every single day you're building, do not underestimate
anybody.
The moment you do, you could be the guy that
becomes the next Tyson.
You could be the guy that loses and comes
back after Golden State's got the greatest
record in the history of NBA, they're 73 -9,
LeBron James comes back after 3-1, and they
beat you.
It could happen to you.
You cannot walk around like you're that bad.
This is why a good ass whooping is good.
Ass whooping could be in business.
Somebody completely crushes you.
A new person comes in and crushes you.
How are you going to respond to that ass whooping?
I got one more or two more left, right?
The other one is going broke.
Going broke.
Going broke is a very good thing that can
happen to you.
Let me tell you why going broke is a good
thing.
Whether you lived in a family that didn't
have a lot of money, whether you lived in
a family that didn't have a lot of money,
or you went broke.
I've experienced both.
I grew up in a family, we didn't have a lot
of money.
We were a welfare family.
And I lost everything.
So I experienced it first hand, when we didn't
have a lot of money, and we lived, you know,
this was pretty tough times, and then I experienced
when I lost everything.
Lost a girl, lost all that stuff.
Both of them, I was in a pretty bad state.
And let me tell you what happens when you
get to this bad state.
You get to this bad state, where you're completely
all alone, by yourself, and there's a part
of you that thinks you're done.
There's a part of you that thinks nothing
else can change.
There's a part of you that wants to throw
in the towel.
And I'm here to tell you, the way you respond
during that heat of the moment in your life,
turns you into the person that gets to creating
losing a habit that lasts a lifetime, or it
becomes a person that rises up and says, you
know what, man, I lost.
This hurts.
I am hurt.
I'm a bit depressed.
I'm a bit shocked.
I have a lot of fears.
But I'm going to fight again.
And you get up and you fight.
If you come back from this, and you fight
and you win, the spirit inside of you, you
know what it believes in?
It believes you can overcome any obstacle.
And that's a very dangerous person to compete
against.
Oh my gosh, you do not screw with people like
that.
You just do not screw with people like that.
Because those people have a certain spirit
that's backing them up.
It's very tough to go against somebody like
that.
Next, betrayal.
Betrayal could be a very good thing.
It happened to me in business a couple of
times.
One was a person that was a good friend, that
we experienced this, and it was a betrayal.
I was shocked that a friend could do something
like this after giving me their word, shook
hands, everything betrayal.
It's a very good thing that happened.
It was a very good thing that happened.
Because it teaches you things.
So betrayal is a good thing in business that
can happen to you.
Because it makes you judge people in a completely
different way.
It keeps your guard up a little bit more to
be paranoid about everybody until you trust
them.
This is one time when I was sitting with Mark
Cuban and Mark Cuban was asked, you know,
you have all these companies that you own,
how do you manage the CEOs.
He said, I micromanage until I trust.
I micromanage until I trust.
When you get betrayed, here's what happens.
You're speed of trust delays.
When we're naive and we're young kids, we
trust faster.
When we get betrayed, now it takes 18 months
to earn my trust.
It used to take three months.
And this is a good thing.
It's not a bad thing.
It's a good thing.
People come and tell me, "Pat, I'm going to
be the greatest salesman you've ever had."
Oh, really?
Yeah, now I give you two years.
Let's see if you're mentally and emotionally
tough.
Can you even handle somebody pushing you.
That's when I know you're legit.
Okay, because it takes longer to trust in
someone's abilities.
It takes longer to trust somebody, maybe a
partner.
It takes longer to put somebody in that position
that you know can go out there and help you
get to the next level.
It takes a little long to do that.
So, betrayal was the last one.
And here's eight things that I'm telling you.
There's a lot of parents that watch this.
And parents, I just want you to know this.
I had some relatives over and the conversation
was, you know, all these things about my dad
was telling stories, and it was all these
people, my sister, all these guys were telling
stories.
And it was, you know, we should have raised
in a different way and we should have done
this and we should have done this and all
this other stuff.
And I said, you know what?
I kind of didn't mind seeing my parents argue.
They said, what are you talking about?
I said, I'm in Panama with my friend Steven
Alfred.
We're in Panama and we're driving to the Panama
Canal and we're driving over there, it's raining
and all this stuff.
I see this four-year-old kid pushing a shopping
cart with a two-year-old kid in it.
There's no parents around.
It's raining.
This four-year-old kid, that visually is still
in my brain, till today.
A four-year-old kid is pushing - I have a
four-year-old son and I have a son that just
turned three.
That's as if my oldest son is pushing my two,
three-year-old son.
And he's pushing him.
And I'm like, what the hell?
Where's the parents?
Where are the parents?
What's going on over here?
Man, that kid is four years old and two years
old and he's got somebody watching over him,
and there's a certain, you know, we're tougher
than we think we are.
We got this thing called survival of the fittest
and we got certain survival mechanisms that
are ingrained in our body that we kind of
know certain things, maybe not as much at
that age, but you see this sometimes taking
place.
And sometimes I see parents protecting their
30-year-old son, as if they're four-years
old.
C'mon, man.
Let this guy get his nose bloody a little
bit.
I did a call one time for a mother and the
son were on the call together.
You remember this, we were at the airport.
I'm doing this call, and the mom's protecting,
protecting, protecting, protecting.
I'm like, let him loose!
He's a baby.
Protect him, protect him, protect him, protect
him.
There's that part, and you see mamas that
raise boys.
I know one right here out of Dallas.
Tough guy.
Two boys, three boys.
They all went to school, all got their four-year
degree.
They all paid for their college.
Mom was disabled growing up.
A kid named Jason.
Tough!
Father wasn't around.
This guy figured out a way to raise his two
younger brothers.
But the mom said, "No excuses.
Get to work.
Get your act together.
You better clean this place.
I don't want a single spot in this place."
Kind of raised three tough boys that they
are all survival right now.
They're doing pretty good for themselves.
This Jason guy made 60, $70,000 this month.
And he's a quality guy.
What happened there?
So parents are watching this, I just want
to encourage you.
Get your kids to be a little bit tougher.
Teenagers, if you're watching this, you want
to grow up being tough, right?
I understand we're living in this politically
correct world where everything's about sensitivity
and don't say this to your kids because it
may stay with them for a very long time.
Honestly, a few scars on you is okay, man.
I don't want a body with no scars.
You know, I want a body with some scars.
Put some scars on me.
It's okay.
You're supposed to have it, makes you tougher.
You last.
You can hang in this world, in this dog-eat-dog
type of world.
You can hang.
And if you're choosing and truly want to become
an entrepreneur, you better get used to some
of these things you're going to get hit, you're
going to get caught.
So don't look at these eight experiences,
bad experiences.
I hope you look at them as some positives,
and I hope it brings up your spirit to realize
you can handle some bigger things in life,
such as entrepreneurship.
With that being said, let's get our pillow
here.
I feel really good today.
I feel really, really good today.
Our old pillow, 2016 made it in two more episodes
for '17 before we launched a new episode.
If you have not subscribed to this channel,
listen.
What are you waiting for?
Click on this button here, it's very easy.
You can do it with your thumb, or you can
do it with your index finger.
I don't know.
You can even do it with your pinkie if you
want, just go click on it.
And then the alert button next to it, click
on that as well, and you'll be the first to
be notified, because we're trying to get this
channel to a million subs by the end of the
year.
There's seven billion people in the world.
If we can get more people around the world
to become entrepreneurs, man, in every single
possible way, innovation improves and makes
everyday life better.
So, with that being said, questions thoughts,
comment on the bottom.
I do read every single one of them.
Thanks so much for watching everybody.
Take care.
Bye bye.